Rollo Rollo how's going guys yeah now
you guys already know my relationship
with food how dependent I am on and how
much I love it how it makes me feel on
the inside and what it does for me
emotionally no but in all honesty just
to reiterate it again I love food I'm
damning food for you the heart is played
in this place
but there is one specific Hawaiian dish
that I absolutely love it's not a dish
that's super fancy is something that
could be eaten at breakfast lunch or
dinner is a local mother obviously this
Hawaiian dish isn't really considered
traditional Hawaiian food but it is
contemporary of line and is one of my
favorite Hawaiian dishes of all time now
the first restaurant that we went to I
did not like this local at all but
everybody else at the restaurant enjoyed
their dishes but [ __ ] but my friends
on another day the saving grace came
from this place called
Hukilau cafe who loved that face food is
exactly what you want from contemporary
Hawaiian dishes the loco moco here was
on point the gravy was super good the
patty was bombed the rice was great but
most importantly was how awesome they
cooked those eggs now if you're a true
foodie out there I know you guys can
appreciate this next clip of this egg
yolk busting all over the food
underneath it
there's something sensual about it egg
yolk cracking over something I don't
know what it is but mid-point is hard
the [ __ ] a boy there's a new one for
penis like contemporary Hawaiian food
doesn't really have what I call a
lightness to it a lot of their plate
lunches are high fat high carb so your
best believe after you eat the food
you're going to feel super satisfied and
you will get a cut nak attack aka the
itis food coma and of course what would
Hawaii be without having one of their
double local restaurants right next to a
[ __ ] even when Hawaii's gloomy it's
absolutely beautiful to me it's just
something about the ambience in the mill
year even though the skies with gray and
the water had this beautiful teal color
to it and you're there with your friends
and family what more could you really
want in life but of course after I eat I
tend not to go in the water because then
I just look like a plump turkey for a
shark to eat [ __ ] y'all probably don't
know this but when I swim in the ocean
I look like an exact replica of a baby
seal
yeah
he is
it's not a matter you
it's gone barely